so you're a company called Duke Energy
in North Carolina you supply electricity
to the states and you've got a pretty
good setup if you've been checking your
power bill lately you may have gotten
your own shock Duke Energy customers in
disbelief over the bills that are much
higher some more than doubled from this
time last year surprisingly the reason
varies drastically depending on which
state you're in now here in Ohio Duke
tells us bills are going up with the
price of natural gas and that jumped
quite a bit last month no 333 dollars is
a big difference between 150 200 so I
was a little Shell Shocked to see that
bill and decades ago you ran into a
problem your Coal Power Plus created a
lot of toxic coal ash you know from
burning the coal toxic coal ash that you
have to dispose of somewhere but
disposing of toxic coal ash safely and
properly is expensive so why not just
throw it into landfills and ponds near
waterways so that's exactly what you did
for decades you polluted major rivers
your toxic coal ash seeped into the
clean groundwater poison the water of
North Carolina homes coal ash first
became to public attention in February
2014 when a coal ash Pond that Duke
Energy operated near the Virginia line
spilled 39 000 tons of Ash into the Dan
River and what did you do when you found
out that this would cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to clean up you
requested that your customers pay for
the entire cost of cleaning up the coal
regular homeowners that were paying for
your electricity were gonna have to Fork
the bill for you polluting their water
what's in the base of the ash Basin now
and what's going to come out over the
next 10 to 15 years depending upon the
facility that's going to be collectively
in the Carolinas eight to nine billion
dollars that cost but unfortunately
after nearly 10 years of litigation you
finally had to agree that the residents
wouldn't have to pay for the entire cost
of the cleanup just most of its the
settlement decided that Duke Energy
would pay for a quarter of the cleanup
costs over the next decade roughly 8
billion dollars leaving your customers
to pay for the other 75 of the cleanup
that you caused and I know I know they
should be really paying for all of it
but we can live for ourselves here after
all you did make well over 18 billion
dollars in profit last year so a billion
dollars in cleanup costs or even paying
from the full four billion dollar bill
will still be a drop in the buckets and
why can you push your customers around
like this because for the 10 million
residents of North Carolina they only
have one Energy company they can turn to
to light up their homes you yes that is
right you have a complete Monopoly over
not just North Carolina but in some of
the neighboring states as well while
being the biggest investor-owned
electricity company in the country which
means you can do whatever you want to
your customers and they will just have
to bend over in tickets but it's not
just North Carolina and these other
states see almost all of America is like
this in America only a few powerful
companies control the entire electric
grid which leaves them free to do
whatever they want to you
stay dangerous and this is the
all-powerful electricity Monopoly of
America
while America's power grid is in
shambles these utility companies are
currently rolling in tens of billions of
dollars and if you have a business that
ships stuff then you have to know about
ship station ship station is the
shipping software that Joe Rogan's audit
brand uses and it's been a complete game
changer for their business it's allowed
them to streamline their shipping so
much that they're able to ship out over
500 orders an hour which would have been
pretty much impossible without ship
station so if ship station is good
enough for Joe Rogan it's probably good
enough for your brand as well that's
because shipstation is the fastest most
affordable way to ship products to your
customers all you got to do is import
your orders from all your selling
channels then you can accelerate your
shipping with all the streamlining tools
while being able to access shipping
discounts of up to 84 and once you ship
out an order shipstation will instantly
update the tracking information to the
selling Channel and the customer they've
got over 130 000 Merchants using
shipstation right now to save time and
drive revenue and the best part is that
you can try it out for free for 60 days
before committing all you gotta do is go
to shipstation.com Jake with the link
below to get your free 60-day trial
that's two months of faster stress-free
shipping at shipstation.com with the
link below thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
foreign
electricity is just as important as food
and water without water you'll die
pretty quickly but without electricity
Society will collapse just as quickly
which is why a monopoly on electricity
is one of the best monopolies you could
ever dream of what are people gonna do
boycott electricity switch providers huh
but the energy Monopoly in America
didn't always seem like such a wild
Injustice it actually made a lot of
sense for the electricity business to
operate this way in the beginning in the
20th century America was going through
the electric Revolution Edison also
developed the first electric power
station which supplied electricity to a
small area of New York City electricity
began to be used for a wide range of
applications including Street lighting
transportation and Industry
electric motors replaced steam engines
in factories making production faster
and more efficient electric street cars
and trains made Transportation more
convenient and comfortable the history
of electricity is a story of innovation
and Progress power plants were growing
bigger and getting more advanced every
single year the bigger they got the
cheaper it became for them to generate
energy and Supply to more people and the
ultimate goal was to get power into
every single building in America and it
was working out well for everyone at
first building a bunch of competing
energy companies all over the place was
just too expensive so it didn't make
sense to have one major Energy company
for a particular region to keep things
as simple as possible Regional energy
monopolies made it easier to distribute
power and originally it didn't make it
cheaper for customers too and it changed
everything electricity spread to every
household Across America but as we
became more reliant on electricity these
energy conglomerates gain more power
more control American utility companies
promised to provide reliable energy at
the lowest possible cost to the region
technically they weren't even supposed
to be profits but they were still
allowed to charge whatever race they
needed to keep the business going so
there was a lot of wiggle room and after
a while all that power got to their
heads soon they got so big so entrenched
that it basically became impractical for
anyone to start a competing company even
if they wanted to and every small energy
provider would just get sucked up by the
Monopoly soon just a few companies were
left to control the entire us power
markets and this Monopoly still has
Americans in a Chokehold to this day and
they were taking full advantage of that
control
foreign
[Music]
there is no reason for these electricity
companies to lower the costs or innovate
to provide a better service in fact
they're actually encouraged by
shareholders to spend as much money as
possible because it UPS the amount
they're allowed to charge the customers
take major energy in New York for
instance major energy was sued for
overcharging its customers and putting
out false advertisements to lure them
into the Trap and they have been doing
this for over a decade the New York
attorney general said we were holding
major energy accountable for misleading
New Yorkers and falsely promising lower
prices but actually overcharging
consumers to make a profits the major
energy isn't the only corrupt one it's
happening all over the states well
meantime a new probe is now zeroing in
on Central Hudson for possible
mismanagement after widespread customer
complaints about erroneous bills for
more than a year now we're talking like
hundreds sometimes even thousands of
dollars in erroneous bills Senator James
goofy says his office has fielded
hundreds of the same complaints about
unexplained High bills from Central
Hudson since last October over and now
the Public Service Commission is
investigating the company's billing
practices for possible mismanagement
after lawmakers demanded a probe once
Central Hudson's executive team found
out this was happening there were loads
of things they should have done could
have done but didn't do to correct this
problem energy companies across the
country randomly raised their rates all
the time because wrongfully charging
their customers a few extra hundred
dollars could mean a few extra billion
dollars for the regional energy Monopoly
and the worst part is that sometimes
these energy monopolies get Reckless and
people end up paying with their lives
foreign
2021 in Texas usually the winter weather
in Texas would hover around a cold 65
degrees around this time of the year but
this time something unusual is happening
a storm is brewing and temperatures
across the state are rapidly dropping
Southeast Texas bracing for a big Arctic
blast let's check back in with Blake for
the very latest Blake you know you can
live in Houston a hundred years and not
see what we're about to experience the
week of Valentine's Day 2021 the
temperature dropped below zero nobody
could remember it being this cold for
this long this was Texas not Siberia and
his record-setting cold temperatures hit
Texas every Texan does the same thing
they turn up their heaters to keep warm
but Texas is the energy State there was
nothing to fear just go home turn on the
heat and hunker down that's how it
should have gone but the paragraph just
couldn't handle the unexpected spike in
usage after all Texas is normally a
pretty warm States so in an instant
prices Skyrocket from 20 per megawatt
hour to nine thousand dollars per
megawatt hour in the state's wholesale
power markets the system failed in
immediately so the energy companies only
had one choice shut it all down
in the blink of a knot in the middle one
of the coldest storms Texas has ever
seen millions of people in Texas lost
power and the concern right now are
these rolling outages these periodic
blackouts that have been going into
effect since early this morning that
leaves up to 2 million Texans without
guaranteed warmth for what looks to be
an incredibly frigid night ahead the
entire State for the first time in
weather history under that winter storm
warning we've got lanterns and little
lights all set up because the power
companies decided to shut everything
down because they couldn't handle a
winter and this wasn't just a little
blackout it was deadly as much as we
knew to get ready for we got ready for
wrapping pipes trying to bleed faucets
stuff like that was really terrifying
there had been a wellness check done and
that an elderly couple had passed away
in their home you're trying all of this
work to help people to literally save
people it feels like you didn't do
enough it was a moment of desperate like
we failed it was a downward spiral where
gas fire caused a power failure caused a
bigger gas failure caused a bigger power
failure people were literally freezing
to death a Texas Department of State
Health Services report shows 246 people
died due to the storm 25 people because
their medical equipment did not have
power
161 mothers fathers children
grandparents froze to death and this
catastrophe costs hundreds of billions
of dollars and reasonably citizens for
outraged and traumatized all the while
the power sellers made billions of
dollars in profit after the demand for
energy went through the roof thanks to
the storm the whole ordeal showed just
how bad the energy system in Texas
really was for years Texas energy
companies were one that their power grid
couldn't handle unexpected weather and
that it desperately needed an upgrade
but they never listened and Texas is far
from the only one the entire country is
on thin ice when it comes to the power
grid as we went over in our recent video
that you should definitely check out
[Music]
energy monopolies know that the key to
their power is eliminating potential
competition and they forth very hard to
ensure that Americans don't have
anywhere else to turn how are they doing
it by turning to their nice little
cronies in Washington power companies
funnel hundreds of millions of dollars
into U.S politics why because a few
hundred million dollars in exchange for
the billions they're making is well
worth the Investments but there is hope
as hard as power companies are fighting
to hold on to their Monopoly competition
is coming Biden recently passed the
defense production act which is supposed
to encourage renewable energy
Manufacturing in America and to help the
solar industry grow now as the world
tries to combat climate change and
switch to clean energy US President Joe
Biden ordered emergency measures to
boost crucial supplies to solar
manufacturers in the country he declared
a two-year tariff exemption on solar
panels from Southeast Asia Biden
suspended tariffs on solar panel imports
from four countries invoke the defense
production act to compel domestic
manufacture of clean energy technology
the bad news is that the solar panel
industry can be even more sketchy than
the traditional energy companies but
we'll say that for a future video so
make sure you click the circle on the
screen to subscribe so how much is Lee
paying
203.50 a month for how long for until
I'm 60 years old so 30 years we now have
70 thousand dollars worth of trash on
our roof it's absolutely false
everything they tell you is a lie for a